democrats are scaling down their plans
to stoop around in your bank account
instead of spying on accounts with 600
bucks the new plan is setting the
threshold at ten thousand dollars
however millions of americans are still
facing a major invasion of privacy from
uncle sam and the white house is trying
to spin the proposal as a way to go
after billionaires and not the average
taxpayer
anywhere where they may be getting a
double w-2 that's not what we're talking
about here they're already reporting
their income what we're talking about
here are people who are high net worth
individuals who are not paying the taxes
they owe something we think everybody
believes should happen and can help pay
for a range of important investments to
make us more competitive
katie federal government
all that waste fraud and pork and
they're going to look at your bank
account i want to look at theirs
yeah joe biden i mean we should look at
that joint bank account we have with
hunter buying it could snoop around and
there but it has more than ten thousand
dollars in it that's for sure this
policy proves that this narrative
they've been trying to sell for two
weeks about this three point five
trillion dollar bill costing zero
dollars is complete garbage because you
know jen sake is up there saying well we
have to do this and we're raising the
threshold to ten thousand dollars but
we're going to go after billionaires who
allegedly aren't paying their taxes when
really it's about paying for this bill
but it's also about government power and
giving democrats more of it saying the
irs needs more power they want to make
sure that banks have to hire more people
to comply with the irs so you get to
hire more irs agents and once you give
them more funding it's always very
difficult to scale it back and it's also
about making sure that gig workers are
completely taken out of the economy
because if you have someone who
is a contractor or maybe doesn't get a
normal w-2 form who works for themselves
or as a business not a corporation then
this is something that they're going to
be looking at you very closely with with
the irs and democrats have made it very
clear they want everyone to be an
employee so they can then be unionized
and so they're lying about the the zero
dollar thing this proves it and the ten
thousand dollar threshold is still way
too low if they're really going after
billionaires trying to get a couple
billion dollars back into the budget
harold do you want your bank working
with the feds on this
no this is the wrong way to go after a
serious issue i think we can all agree
the number's too low ten thousand
dollars is too low to snoop in
everyone's account i think what they're
trying to get at is how do you make the
tax code fairer our first issue was
immigration immigration and taxes we've
not had a comprehensive reform on either
of those issues since 1986 ronald reagan
was president we need to have one this
effort here kind of immature kind of
sophomoric if you're really serious
about it bring in rich people who've
been able to get away without paying
their taxes who are democrats and say
what should we be doing in the code to
ensure that we don't allow just the rich
not even just the rich the ultra rich to
avoid uh avoid taxes i think we can all
harold i think we trainers i think we
can all agree that that if you people
who live their lives in in shielded
income should pay taxes and i think
that's the point now your point katie is
i agree with six hundred dollars ten
thousand dollars you're going to hire
people they're not really going to get
the crux of this you got to get to
bigger accounts and i think the gig
economy i'm not convinced democrats want
everybody unionized but i do believe
that democrats want a fair tax code at
least that's what i want i don't think
this is the right way to do it i think
thematically they're right practically
they're wrong ten thousand dollars in
looking accounts is not going to solve
this problem dean it's a good thing you
keep all your money offshore yeah
was i supposed to say that
i'm sorry
that's i mean it's i learned um from the
best because gutzell told me that years
ago
so here's the thing they got caught yeah
the democrats thought they could slip
this by you because remember when
obamacare passed and it was only
afterwards that everything wait what all
these things and then it became super
unpopular and it
mounted uh in its toxicity so that's
what happened here so congressman jim
banks from indiana he runs a republican
study committee he has his team go
through with this thing with the fine
tooth comb and they find this thing and
you you have to realize that the
democrats putting this in there it's
like the worst bond villain of all time
like i know we are so popular that we
should try to give a lot more money to
the most unpopular entity in the federal
government the irs and it completely
backfired on them and the other thing to
katie's point that if the bill doesn't
cost anything if it costs zero then you
wouldn't need this anyway exactly yeah
they want to uh investigate the border
patrol but they want to give the irs
agents a raise yeah but
just 10 grand that's like if you buy a
car down payment on a house two months
plus deposit in new york city probably
in brooklyn so you're you get you're
scooping up a lot of people uh i think
permission to bash the media permission
granted yeah i know it's rare so how did
this happen happen the media has
constantly obsessed with
authoritarianism as though it comes from
the right and that's probably because
they are not part of the right hate
republicans so they always envision that
it's going to be trump or somebody
before trump bush before bush it was
reagan
uh are going to like are going to you
know create an authoritarian dystopia
but then when you look at it
they miss the impulse of the left it's
there whether it's communist china it's
the stalin soviet union ho chi minh
these are all left wingers i can't
imagine trump wanting to snoop through
anybody's bank accounts no republican
would do that so if you look at all this
stuff and you step back and you look at
the speech codes on campus and the vax
mandates targeting parents who just want
to protect their kids from crappy
education
we are we are barreling towards an
authoritarian utopia and there's not a
single republican fingerprint on it not
a single one nope it's all academics
it's all it's all
politicians progressives wokesters
they're all there yeah and if this
passes fox has to pay me in bitcoin yes
that's that's not even a negotiation pay
me in bitcoin
right all of us will get paid in bitcoin
up next more massive foreign policy
failures pile up for the president how
biden got caught completely off guard by
china hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else